foreign
Pennsylvania what's that Joseph
hey Dr John how are you I'm all right my
brother what you doing
oh man am I nervous
dude I'm I'm not that good at this man
there's nothing to be nervous about
I'm way more nervous than you I promise
what's up yeah I I hear you hey um well
first I wanted to say thank you I've
been listening to you for over two years
and uh
thank you and to your whole team over
there at Ramsey um you gave me and my
wife some tools to better our lives and
y'all are awesome dude thank you so so
much I appreciate you being in our gang
for a couple years man that's awesome
awesome just getting started dude I'm
grateful for you
um
quickly I think I need to provide a
little bit of context for our situation
for my question to actually resonate
sure if that's cool okay so I have some
notes here written down so uh you got it
about three and a half years ago I made
the decision to pretty much change my
ways to kind of save my marriage and my
family
um I'm sorry I'm I'm really nervous
that's okay hey um do you mind if I stop
you and and clarify some things as
you're reading that
yeah sure okay
um what did you have to change
um so that's what I'm about to get into
so I was
um drinking more than I should had a
horrible tobacco habit was very
overweight okay uh miserable angry
hard-headed
um and all that I thought I knew
everything and then uh
what really changed when I started
listening and to your show um you say
you know you have to lay your your sword
and your shield down and uh so I did
um and then listening to the Ramsay show
as well I mean it I mean you guys like
forever changed my life man and and I'm
appreciative of that so I appreciate
that we do we just run it we just run
our outs man you actually did the work
you're the one that yeah I mean that's
that's a generation's worth of behaviors
you changed right
yes sir yeah now
um we were in our early 30s and
tobacco-free hardly ever drink I mean
wake up early gym six days a week read
books my marriage is I mean so much
better than I thought it ever could be
you lose weight
yeah man um 50 pounds oh man congrats
dude thank you thank you um we built a
net worth of about 425 000.
um so wow yeah dude yeah that's a total
slap it up flip it reversion dude how do
you how do you uh
how do you feel
well see that's kind of well part of my
reason for the call is man I feel great
like physically
um emotionally I feel
um you know since I I started to become
more vulnerable open-minded man I feel
so much better like just so much more
pure so much easy like easy life is
easier you know what I mean that that
word is that magic word of peace dude
like it's right it's just like like I
cut you off in traffic and you're like
all right dude have a good day like you
know I mean like I don't feel like I
gotta kill him right that is exactly one
of my main things is is to like just let
him go man his you know what I mean his
day is his day and let him roll you know
what I mean man you're gonna live ten
years longer just just on that alone
awesome okay so what where where are we
here what what what's the purpose of the
call yeah so so proud of you dude you're
awesome yeah thank you so much
um yeah so I say all this stuff all this
good I mean it is good but I still
always felt this gap between my wife and
I
um that was bigger than any money saved
or weight loss you know what I mean so
we've become way more open with each
other over the past year and she has
told me
um just recently that uh this is hard um
uh when she was 15 she had consensual
sex with a 22 year old and no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no she
didn't she did notes on my notes I have
consensual in quotes yes she did not she
was raped by an adult exactly so
whenever she told me this
um she she started off by saying don't
look at me
um so she had shame all over her you
know what I mean and then
um I I explained I tried to explain to
her you know before she kept going that
it wasn't her fault you know what I mean
that that was an adult that took
advantage of a child right so good for
you um
yeah so but I still feel like symptoms
show up of that and like her daily life
and I guess my primary focus and my
primary question is like how to love her
the best I can and close this like final
Gap that I feel is still there that
derives from the crime the man committed
over 15 years ago yeah
um and she's never really had someone
where she can go to and just be her
right so like
um apparently her mom she couldn't go to
her mom you know and early in our
marriage which is why I led with all of
that was I wasn't that guy either
because I would have just gotten raged
out I would have just you know what I
mean what's his name we're not you know
this and that um
and so that's kind of where we're at now
and also I mean I need to forgive myself
for not being that guy
um at the beginning of our marriage you
know what I mean and I don't know how to
do that yeah
um there's several things here one a
couple of them are going to be hard to
hear and then a couple of them I think
you can take the bull by the horns okay
okay um
you have
um you have done some
extraordinary life transformation
at some point along this journey and
that word is so like woo-woo and
spiritual like Gwyneth Paltrow and
that's I don't even like using it but it
is what it is like on this path that
you're on
you at some point will look up and
realize Oh I thought I was doing it for
this but I was actually doing it for
this
here's what I mean for most of us I
would say 99.9 of us we have to have a
Finish Line to get up
I'm not just gonna go train for seven
months to run on a Saturday morning at
five in the morning with ten thousand
strangers unless I know how far we're
running
and if they just said go you know what I
mean like I don't like are we going 26
miles are we going Four Mile like so
almost all of us have to get up and go
towards the finish line and that's what
you've done
I want to change my family tree I want
to be a better husband I just want to
feel good when I get up in the morning
for God's sake I want to laugh more than
I'm pissed off like but all of that was
towards
I want to accomplish this thing
okay and what you're finding out is
there's a limit to that because you can
only control you
and somebody else has to participate in
a marriage where both people are
constantly giving themselves up for the
other person
and so I tell you all that to tell you
you are on this path not to get a better
marriage you'll get a better marriage
along the way
you're not on this path just to lose
weight you will lose weight because
you're a guy who honors himself and his
family and his community by taking care
of his body
right so you're playing an infinite game
here and your kids are going to pick
that up and their kids are going to pick
that up and you'll have changed
generations of your family
and so
what you're finding out in real time is
you have quit one of the most difficult
habits on the planet which is nicotine
addiction you have quit one of the most
challenging
uh addictions in the planet which is
alcoholism because that's relational in
nature which meant you had to go get
connected with a real person instead of
pseudo-connected with a bottle right you
have done one of the most impossible
things which is lose 50 pounds
right you've done all this stuff
and you can't control your wife and her
healing
and you have to sit in that
powerlessness and say okay the more I
try to solve this problem for her
the worse I'm going to make it because
what that 22 year old did was he took
her autonomy away
right he took that and does that make
sense yeah it does and just to be clear
she um she's realizing you know she's
she's in it um she wants to
um you know what I mean I just want to
know you know what can I do to help
guide her to help you know just be there
I did write her a letter the day after
she told me
um and she did keep it
um and she she she's all in she and she
listens to your show as well so she'll
be hearing this call too it's awesome um
yeah and so she she is I just want to
know like is there you know should we go
to like is there a marriage there is
there an exercise we could do well no
there will be there will be there will
be marriage counseling at at which
here's what she's got to learn to do
number one
um the way she framed that interaction
you nailed it on the head she is her the
the blood that pulses through her veins
is shame
is disgust and it's discussed the way
she framed it I did this at 15. I chose
this at 15. no you didn't
all right right
um and so or yeah you chose that and you
were not in a position to make that
choice because you're a child right
um and so
the last thing we want to do is go in
and say okay let's do this thing so you
can fill in the blank or I've got this
exercise which she's gonna have to learn
over time is a this is not your fault
and not just learn that cognitively her
body has to come to understand that
she's also going to have to learn
um that
uh what's the right way like
that her she's gonna have to learn that
she has the power to make decisions and
choices for her life and learn how to
carry the responsibility for that
inappropriate way not and then like I'm
just carrying the whole thing myself
and so a great gift you can give her is
to ask her on a daily basis
how can I best love you today
and here's what she's gonna do she's
going to practice saying like nothing
I'm good nope give me one thing would
you honor me enough by giving me one way
I can love you today
I could do that and
um if she's okay with it and this isn't
the first for all um sexual assault rape
victims everybody's different right
um I've seen it very very powerful
healing is just can we hold hands
um and maybe touch bare feet like under
the covers can we just do it for five
minutes
and this is something we're gonna do
not so that you can get lucky or you
might right that might be something
you'll agree on but that's not the point
isn't like hey I know how to get this
ball rolling that's not it it's right I
want her to rest in you
exactly okay and it's gonna be something
she has to learn it's not learned like
cognitively she loves you and trust you
she wouldn't have married you she
wouldn't have been creating a life with
you her body has to feel that other men
are okay
and she may be there dude she may be
there but my guess is it's hard to be
sexually intimate with somebody who
thinks they're disgusting from the
inside out yeah and that's the that's
the one thing like that I I'm trying to
show her is you know I think that she
truly lacks confidence and and honestly
there's I mean she's a beautiful she's
amazing she's smart you know I married
way up you know I mean most of us did
man most of us did hey but I want her I
want you to listen to the language I
want to show her this is not a theater
performance I'm going to be I'm going to
be with her
okay okay so not how can I demonstrate
how beautiful you are how can I
demonstrate how much I love you that's a
show
okay
what do you need to feel safe today
and that might mean I'm gonna go get the
milk you all have kids
yeah too that might mean I'm doing
bedtime
okay that might mean I I call and get a
neighborhood knucklehead teenager to
come over and watch the kids because
we're gonna go for a walk
okay like what's give me one thing give
me two things
that we can do to love you and then I
can that I can love you and it's it's
not a matter of I'm showing you it's I'm
here and you can't get rid of me because
I'm I love you that much
um I want to make your life better
and that's a different thing does that
make sense it sounds like it's semantics
but it's not it's it's a it's another
level and then there will come there'll
come a season yeah man y'all will go to
a marriage counselor and it won't be a
million sessions probably but you'll
learn some things
and there'll be some hard moments that
you're gonna say God I wish you had told
me that 10 years ago and she's gonna say
I didn't have the language I didn't know
how and you're gonna find out that you
did some things that made her body feel
like back in and you're gonna feel all
weirded out and grossed and that's part
of this healing Journey that you're on
together
and the only person you can control this
whole thing is you
yeah so no I that makes that makes
perfect sense I mean I completely
understand and that's something that you
know we're definitely going to look into
and you know it's actually I don't know
how to say this but like
almost like the we've done so much of
the hard work already alone with books
and you know
um listening to podcasts and just being
more open that now I feel like you know
if we were to go talk to someone
it would be almost just uh I don't want
to say quick and easy
um no no hey trust me it's not gonna be
quick and easy it's gonna be a mess but
here you were right you've learned all
of the lingo
and you've cognitively put all the stuff
in your head let me put it this way
you've watched a lot of basketball games
it's different when you get on the floor
right right and someone starts boxing
you out and they stuff your shot and
they just dribble right around you like
now you know how to play basketball
you've watched it a lot you even know
how the plays work now you gotta get on
the floor and start practicing and
you're gonna fall down you're gonna get
knocked over that's just gonna be part
of it
um but yeah that's you're way ahead of
the game you'll be able to sit down with
the therapist and I mean just reading
what you just wrote me
um makes me believe your wife won the
lottery with you
yeah I mean just god you're an amazing
guy dude you're an inspiration to all of
us
um and but hold on and
that's there's going to come a point
when there's a we if it's not there
already that's a weird challenge for her
I can never live up to the husband he is
and that feeds the of course not
you were X Y and Z back when you were
15. you've always been right and it
feeds an opposing narrative right so
you're not gonna
be more of a sucky husband to lower the
bar no but you're gonna be really
graceful to take a knee and say hey how
can I love you today
and she's gonna practice saying what she
needs and then when you give it to her
not immediately going I don't deserve
this
but her going that's right because I'm
his wife I'm the I'm the woman he chose
because he loves me right
it's gonna and it's gonna be this
practice this practice is practice but
dude yeah you gotta you got a hellacious
journey ahead of you and y'all are way
down the road man that's awesome yeah I
got you I'm awesome and kudos to you
um
laughs
kudos to you for not immediately jumping
in and trying to solve this for her
foreign
good for you man because I think that's
most of our impulse is
sweet time to go to war
and we often do the very thing that
somebody who assaulted our loved ones
did which is take away their autonomy we
take away their decision making we take
away what they want you don't get a vote
I'm going to war because this is about
my ego and me winning and my possession
which is my wife or my husband
and you listened and you wrote a letter
that I'm assuming said
I'm here with you
till the end of time
she will reread and reread and reread
that letter my brother
she's lucky to have you man stay on the
path stay on the path stay on the path
let me know how this this uh plays out
man I'd love to know how her counseling
goes and um I'd love to walk with you
guys as y'all stay on this journey
appreciate you